einen Tag nach dem Deutschland verkündet
hat Leopard Panzer an die Ukraine zu
liefern treffen wir serreische revati er
ist der Sprecher des ostkommandos der
ukrainischen Armee
aus militärischer Sicht und so wie
dieser Krieg gerade verläuft was
bedeutet diese Entscheidung jetzt für
Sie das Deutschland jetzt ja gesagt hat
dass Leoparden geliefert werden die USA
liefern auch Panzer
startet danke
in Wirklichkeit ist es eine große
Entscheidung die es uns erlaubt unsere
Territorien schneller zu befreien und
dies nicht nur um den ehrgeizwillen oder
wegen bestimmter militärischer Pläne
sondern weil es damit in Verbindung
steht dass unsere Bevölkerung nicht mehr
leiden soll
überall wo wir Territorien befreit haben
und die Ukraine hat mit der Hilfe die
uns früher schon seitens unserer Partner
geleistet wurde bereits vieles befreit
damit meine ich die Kia ihre Region den
Norden der Ukraine die Region um hakiv
niemand Person
überall wo die Befreier wie die Russen
sich selbst nennen waren hat man das
erste Zeichen von rustimir der
russischen Welt gesehen und zwar die
Folterkammern
[Musik]
es gab Vergewaltigung Ermordungen
Menschen deren Leben zerstört wurden
traumatisierte Kinder Kinder die
entführt wurden und nach Russland
verschleppt wurden
und dass wir jetzt diese Waffen
übergeben bekommen das beschleunigt
nicht nur unseren Sieg das verkürzt das
Leiden all dieser Menschen die sich
nichts haben zu Schulden kommen lassen
auch nicht Russland gegenüber sie waren
aber gezwungen dass alles über sich
ergehen zu lassen
und natürlich ist es eine große Hilfe
wenn wir von der humanitären Komponente
sprechen
was die militärische Komponente angeht
dann lässt sich sagen die westliche
Zivilisation hat uns jetzt die besten
Panzer der Welt übergeben das ist ohne
jeden Zweifel der Leopard 2 eine der
besten Maschinen Abrams und Challenger
leoparden sind außerdem noch symbolisch
denn in den Köpfen der Ukraine hat alles
Deutsche immer ein Gütezeichen und das
stimmt ohne weiteres was Sicherheit der
Panzerbesatzung betrifft was
aufklärungs- und beobachtungsmittel
betrifft was Tages- und Nachtzeiten
betrifft was Leistung der Waffe angeht
ist es für diese Technik möglich sowohl
die verteidigungsoperation durchzuführen
als auch Offensive Maßnahmen was noch
wichtiger ist es ermöglicht uns den
Feind von unserem Territorium zu
vertreiben
bald besucht sie unser neuer
Verteidigungsminister sie haben es ja
mitbekommen was möchten Sie ihm gerne
zeigen oder mitteilen
ich kann ihn nur sagen was ich ihm
zeigen wollen würde damit werden sich
aber vor allem unser Außenminister und
Verteidigungsminister beschäftigen und
ich bin mir sicher die wissen ganz genau
was sie ihnen zeigen wollen ich möchte
dass der neue deutsche
Verteidigungsminister sieht dass die
Ukraine fest entschlossen sind die Hilfe
vom deutschen Volk zu nutzen um die
Gerechtigkeit wieder herzustellen unsere
Grenzen wieder herzustellen
und danach zusammen mit Deutschlands
Erfahrung sowohl die Zivilgesellschaft
als auch die Verteidigung nach
europäischen Standards wieder aufzubauen
was die Etappen des Krieges angeht ich
habe mit dem Berater des Präsidenten
michalow podoljak gesprochen er meinte
dass dies der tiefste schwierigste Punkt
dieses Krieges ist
in der Tat das ist für die Russen von
größter Bedeutung sie haben den Chef
ihres Generalstabs die wichtigste
militärperson für diese Operation
eingesetzt sie haben alles Militärische
was sie viele Jahre gespart haben in die
Waagschale geworfen
für die Russen geht es vor allem darum
unseren Willen zu Verteidigung zu
brechen neben Militäroperationen werden
eben auch Kampagnen mit Desinformationen
durchgeführt
wir waren glaube ich die ersten
Journalisten die die Möglichkeit hatten
sich die Panzerhaubitzen anzusehen
nachdem die geliefert wurden
funktionieren sie alle
da sollte ich noch genauer nachfragen
die werden aber alle sehr intensiv
genutzt und das ist auch für Deutschland
eine wichtige Erfahrung inwieweit sich
dieser sehr intensive Einsatz auf die
Panzerhaubitzen auswirkt
natürlich möchten die Deutschen wissen
welchen Unterschied zum Beispiel diese
Panzerhaubitzen gemacht haben und welche
Erfolge sie an der Front gebracht haben
das ist eine sehr leistungsfähige Waffe
von sehr guter Qualität
nato-kaliber 155
so war es für uns möglich auch Munition
im Westen zu besorgen weil der Krieg
seitdem
24.2.2022 so intensiv wurde dass
sowjetische Munition nicht mehr
ausreichte Kaliber 152 und 122
es mangelte uns schon damals an Munition
und die Russen werden jetzt mit diesem
Problem konfrontiert
das war also auch die Sache mit Kalibern
und selbstverständlich was das Ziel und
schlagsystem betrifft die Waffe ist sehr
präzise und effizient der einzige
Nachteil in Anführungszeichen besteht
darin dass sie noch nie so intensiv
eingesetzt wurde
[Musik]
und ich denke nach diesem Krieg nach
unserem Sieg kann man diese
Betriebsparameter analysieren um zu
verstehen dass bei so einem intensiven
Krieg auch eine so gute Waffe besondere
Wartung und Analyse braucht damit sie
benutzt werden kann
die Ukraine bekommt jetzt eine Menge
Waffen geliefert reicht das aus um ihre
Ziele zu erreichen
y hat gesagt dass wir 300 Panzer
brauchen glaube ich 600 oder 700 von
Infanterie und Kampffahrzeugen 500
Haubitzen
jetzt wie ich das auf Anhieb einschätzen
kann haben wir die Anzahl noch nicht
erreicht aber wir kommen dem Ziel immer
näher da bin ich sicher
niemand in Europa hat mit einem Krieg
von solcher Intensität gerechnet
wir haben alle gedacht dass eine neue
Ära eingetroffen ist und Menschen ihre
Fragen auf eine andere Art und Weise
klären mit Hilfe von weicher macht einem
Dialog der Wirtschaft und so weiter
doch als wir mit dieser Situation
konfrontiert wurden haben wir und
mittlerweile auch unsere Partner
verstanden wenn wir diesen fein schlagen
wollen brauchen wir nur auf die Karte zu
gucken es braucht keine großen Argumente
sondern viel Kraft
wir brauchen Panzertechnik wir brauchen
ernsthafte Artillerie natürlich wäre es
für uns ideal wenn wir noch etwas von
der Luftwaffe kriegen würden
Militärhubschrauber Kampfflugzeuge wir
nehmen alles dankbar an und nutzen es
auch wie unser Präsident bereits
erwähnte das sind Investitionen nicht
nur in unserer Sicherheit sondern in die
Sicherheit von ganz Europa
leider verlieren wir jetzt viele
Menschenleben
aber ich bin mir sicher dass sobald
dieses böse bekämpft wird wird es
positive Wirkungen auf alle Länder haben
auf dem europäischen Kontinent mit
Sicherheit
das was wir heute sehen die heutige
Situation in der Ukraine das Angriffe im
ganzen Land erwartet werden ist das eine
Antwort Russlands auf die gestern
beschlossene Hilfe oder waren diese
Angriffe bereits früher
[Musik]
geplantieren
ich würde auf diese Frage 2 Antworten
geben
putinen und seine Umgebung mögen Symbole
verschiedene Daten gestern war ja der
Geburtstag unseres Präsidenten das fiel
auch mit dem Entschluss zusammen und
diese Technik zu liefern das könnte ein
zusätzlicher Grund dafür sein aber
insgesamt ist es ihre Taktik schon seit
ein paar Monaten die Städte anzugreifen
um den Willen unserer Bevölkerung zu
brechen was die Russen für möglich
halten
sie verstehen so wenig von unserem Volk
dass sie denken je mehr Sie unsere
Städte angreifen umso schneller wird die
Bevölkerung die politischen Eliten dazu
bringen den militärischen Widerstand zu
beenden und ein Abkommen zu schließen
sie haben erneut bewiesen dass sie uns
nicht kennen genauso wie es am Anfang
des Krieges der Fall war als sie gedacht
haben mit der Angst die sie versucht
haben uns einzuladen und der massiven
militärischen Kraft könnten Sie unseren
Sieges Willen brechen das macht uns im
Gegenteil härter dass wir von unseren
Partnern unterstützt werden von
Deutschland als führender europäischer
macht gibt uns Kraft und Klarheit dass
wir auf der richtigen Seite der
Geschichte stehen
dass wir im Recht sind weil wir unser
Volk verteidigen
und da an unserer Seite die westliche
Gesellschaft ist kämpfen wir nicht nur
für unsere Identität und um das Recht
Ukrainer genannt zu werden der kämpfen
wahrscheinlich um das Recht Europäer
genannt zu werden